what's worse is when he caught the
cheating he immediately tried to fight
the guy he lost no
that's 50 50. like you need to both put
in the effort well
and the women should support the men
what kind of decisions are you talking
about every big decision no see that's
part my job I know but that's the
problem is we want jobs more than we
want families that's the problem do you
want me to make money or do you want me
to be a stay-at-home mum you know I want
my kids to be less social because
there's so many lunatics out there
there's so many lunatics I wanna I wanna
vet every person my kid talks to what up
guys welcome to the just pearly things
YouTube channel and welcome to my Series
where I read pill women welcome to the
show thank you for having me introduce
yourself to the people hello everyone my
name's Sophia
um I'm originally from Australia and now
I live in London so um today I'm gonna
be showing you a mgtow video so you know
all right so have you ever heard of
mgtow nice all right so mgtow stands for
men going their own way right okay do
you do you have you ever noticed a group
of men that don't want relationships and
just or they don't want to deal with
women no I know because pretty women
will never notice this no I never have
no no no it's okay it's okay this
actually proves the point a bit further
but but so men going their own ways
basically and you you know nothing about
this so I don't expect you to know
anything okay okay so the divorce says
the marriage laws discriminate against
men so when men having ever heard the
phrase it's cheaper to keep her happy
wife happy life yes so so basically
there's a lot of men that are really
tired of the women leaving taking their
kids and taking their money I'll give
you a couple stats like um women only
get custody or men only get custody 10
20 of the time
um because the courts favor the women
why did I do that uh well there's a
couple reasons one is that the way men
typically pay more right yeah and I I
think they should be rewarded for that
however the the way that the courts do
it is if you make more money and the the
wife spends more time with the kids we
should award the wife custody so it's
kind of like a gotcha moment where it's
like he's doing the right thing right
he's working yeah and paying for his
kids and he's he's punished for it
doesn't make sense it doesn't I I think
it should be 50 50 off the bat great or
or when you think about it the one who
can afford it yeah because if you can't
afford the kid then why why are you
having it correct it's the same thing
when I buy a dog if I couldn't afford it
right and so it's like if you if you
bought a dog with your boyfriend and
only one of you could afford dog food
the one who could afford the dog food
would probably do it but with the kids
they think that they should like take
the money and like give it to the men
basically it was child support alimony
there's a bunch of government programs
that do this okay so so are we we
continue
um so these are some of the thoughts of
some of the men that are just done with
women
um all right let's so this is how what
do you think about men dating single
mothers would you want your brother to
date a single mother no but if he was in
that position and he was mentally and
financially there and he could accept
that then right but if he had two girls
one had a kid one didn't have a kid who
would you tell him to pick the one that
didn't have a kid because there's less
stress on him correct yes yes because we
love our brothers we don't want them
dealing you know I want him to be okay
yes so this is the video stay away from
single mothers however one same being
here this video is brought to you by a
donation from t-ben and here's what he
has to say hello Sandman long time no
see I wanted to give you two stories
about single mothers that I've
experienced a few months ago I was on my
way home from work when I spotted a car
stuck in the middle of the road I walked
over to see what was up with this
individual and apparently she ran out of
gas I helped push her vehicle out of the
way and offered to take her to the
nearest gas station I didn't realize she
had three children in the back of her
car until she told me but I still
continue to offer my help now please
don't mistake me for simping for this
woman my reason for doing this was for
job status not sex and at this job that
I work at they give big bonus checks
with an employee of the month award for
stuff like this now back to the story as
I helped this woman with her children I
began to get more uncomfortable and
annoyed but not by the children but by
the single mom she was very verbally and
physically to her children and then
asked me if I had a girlfriend or
significant other I said yes and I tried
my best to stay out of her parenting
business but the this person could not
keep track of her own kids one nearly
wandered into oncoming traffic where I
had to guide it back to the sidewalk
after we got the gas and headed back to
her car one of her children was sleeping
in the car while I was pouring the gas
entertained by my shock I saw her yank
that child out of the car to the ground
and by the way all of her children were
under the age of 10. I had to give her a
few words of parenting 101 for that
scene I just witnessed I told myself I
don't think that the employee of the
month award is ever worth doing this
again
[Laughter]
control their kids have never seen a
single mom who can't control her kid do
you know any single mothers a day and
they all control their kids all their
kids are super well behaved you could
like take them to dinner they would
behave well I think she could yeah okay
okay so you could think of one that's
good yeah okay stories about a friend of
mine who took his own life he was dating
this weird chick with a lot of red flags
I and many others brought it to his
attention several times but he just
ignored us and said that what they had
going on together not even signed so the
devil herself could break up too bad he
didn't realize that he was dating a
She-Devil what caused his self-deletion
was that he found out that she had
basically been playing him the whole
time the two kids he thought he
conceived with her weren't his and that
she what do you think about women that
lie to dads about paternity don't lie in
the first place do you think that those
women should go to jail for lying if the
guy spent years raising the kids I don't
think they should go to jail but I think
there should be consequence okay what
about men that dip out on their kids and
worse or deadbeat dads and refuse to pay
child support should they go to jail no
no okay so you you would make it neither
of them go to jail yeah okay that's only
fair okay what's worse is when he caught
the cheating he immediately tried to
fight the guy he lost I gotta go no no
what did that say I can't even think of
anything worse as a man oh so he caught
his um his the mother he thought he
thought this girl was raising his kids
so he found out that the two kids
weren't his and then the dude she was
cheating with he tried to fight and he
lost the fight and now I'm like that's
so embarrassing yeah that's probably why
she said
before he committed the sorry were they
the other guy that she was cheating on
his kids yeah I think so I if I
understood the story right yeah he
immediately tried to fight the guy he
lost I got a call from him just a week
before he committed the self-deletion
ACT telling me all of this and asking me
about what I should do I told him
destroy everything and leave it all
behind because it's not worth building
back I told him to start someplace else
fresh and new but he just kept saying
but I love her I can't live without her
I told him you're going to have to
because what you love is evil and it's a
demon and it doesn't deserve love he
told me okay and hung up the phone and
last week was the week I found out that
he ended it all so let this be a lesson
to all the men out there which is to
stay away from the single mothers Walt
even thanks for the donation have you
ever seen your brother date a girl that
was bad for him yes yeah and what kind
of effects did that have on him a lot of
mental issues yeah going in the wrong
direction choosing the wrong crowd to
hang out with but I can see that's why
you're a bit more selective with the
like because a lot of girls won't say
not to date single moms yeah but you
actually because you have brothers yeah
I put three brothers and two sisters
yeah oh wow you have a big family yeah
I'm number five of six wow yeah the big
family
um but yeah so you can kind of see where
you understand a bit where they're
coming yeah because a lot of girls will
say no date The Single Moms yeah I get
their perspective day onto why they
would but then I would be like don't do
it because it's more stress on the man
correct well and honestly I would say if
a girl can date a guy without kids yeah
do the same but but it's also like women
kind of like men with kids but men don't
like women with kids and I don't
understand why I yeah but you know it's
a thing yeah it is a thing but I just
don't get why yeah well I'll tell you
why there's okay so just because we're
in a modern times it doesn't change our
biology yeah so what what is a female
mating strategy at its core didn't they
so you want to get the best jeans
possible oh yeah so you want to get like
that that's why you like tall men strong
men because it's better jeans for the
kids right yes and you want to get as
many resources as possible yes so like
the money that's why we have gold
diggers what's a male Strat mating
strategy to its core I want to pass on
my genes yeah we're obviously like um to
a fertile a fertile woman and attractive
woman so that's why men tend to date
younger women because we we're more
fertile yeah okay so so the reason the
reason that men
um that women like men with kids is
because when a man has a kid it shows
that he has resources and it shows that
another woman picked him so if another
woman picked him to have a kid with that
means that she selected him therefore he
must have something worthwhile like why
do you think all these women keep making
kids with Nick Cannon right you know
Nick Cannon is nice okay he's got 11
baby mothers yeah but but there's and
they they are crazy right but there's a
reason they're crazy and the reason is
if he like it back in the olden days
right before this whole modern society
you would see a caveman and if he had
another cave woman that means he's
protecting her and giving her resources
so yeah if you go for him then he can
protect both of you like more only 40 of
men have reproduced so it's always been
two women to one man yes yeah yeah so I
do agree with that yeah so on the other
I mean haven't you ever noticed like
women even getting cheated on right yeah
you know most men can't cheat most men
it's just only the men that you see can
cheat so okay so women on dating apps we
swipe right five percent of the time
okay yeah so and women we think eighty
percent of men are ugly right so if
we're all if we all think 80 of men are
ugly who are we dating the same men yeah
so yeah right right so so if he could
cheat your ex-boyfriend right yeah no no
shame I've been cheated on two we all we
all have we everybody has yeah but but
the whole point is that like you picked
someone that could yeah when most guys
can't meaning meaning in a way he had
multiple women and there were signals
that showed that that you were attracted
to it's not conscious like most of the
time we don't know why we're doing what
we do yeah but there's a reason you like
confidence confident men tend to get
laid yeah that's true yeah yeah yeah
yeah the same as confident women like no
no I don't know yeah I don't think the
girls and only fans are very I guess
maybe they're outwardly some of them not
all yeah small small percentages yeah
but but men don't really care about
confidence they prefer humility yeah
yeah you're not wrong yeah
women always say they want to be
confident but if you're con like men
don't like that they like humility I
mean they don't want a girl that's super
insecure but no they want you to have
some confidence they want you to be
though they want you to be pretty but
not know it like their ideal huh
I'll discuss your two stories in just a
moment but let me first tell everyone
about today's sponsor the red pill ring
do it fast before Gollum with boobs
stops you anyways now back to the kuch
in a car with their kids in the back
clown world show who runs out of gas in
the middle of a city I've also seen
women that lock themselves out of their
car while the engine was still running
or that didn't do oil changes because
apparently no one told them they had to
thus they destroyed their engines but to
be fair I've locked my keys in the car
before twice both times I left them it
was on the passenger seat one time I was
driving across the country in South
Dakota and was tired but I still had my
phone and wallet on me and ended up
calling AAA and they opened the door for
me I was running on only two to three
hours of sleep this woman should have
paid the extra 50 or 60 dollars a year
for AAA as they would have come by and
filled up her car with gas and sent her
on her Merry way I also get a towing
range of around 60 or 70 miles as well
for that price but this isn't an ad for
AAA or Cas it's called in Canada CA
offices look like pimped up travel
stores that sell you vacation packages
too as well as luggage and they're
filled with women trying to sell you
insurance and other things that you
don't eat you can tell this woman is a
single mother simply because she doesn't
have a husband or boyfriend to call for
help when she runs out of gas when she
starts asking about your relationship
status TVN then you know for sure about
her single mother status I'm not sure
about the other story though the woman
that ran out of gas and probably wanted
you to go up her ass through her actions
was saying I'm a horrible human being
and I'm showing you at my worst if
you're single and still willing to date
me a single mother when I children this
much then you'll probably take the
yourself instead maybe the plan was to
make you feel sorry for her kids so that
you would step in and be the one she
stand out of sympathy she saw that you
were willing to defend her kids perhaps
this is more than just a case of an
incompetent single mother stupidly
running out of gas in the middle of the
road is it possible that she's trusting
it even to see if she can get a white
nine-man John that sacrifice his life
for her kids while simultaneously taking
hers there's a reason she's single to
begin with and it's probably a guy that
said to himself you know what I can't
take this anymore it's better that she
treats her own kids like that instead of
me and he basically headed for the hills
then again she might not be single at
all and instead of calling hubby for
help who's going to get livid with her
she's choosing to get a Sim to help out
instead I hope you didn't end up paying
for the gases she'd rather be a red flag
and be abusive and I see why the guy
would have left if she is a kid she's
going to babysit to the yeah parent like
yeah there's a whole generation of women
that are just terrible others yeah and I
don't get it yeah well it's because
we've been told we live in this Society
where they just tell us the only thing
that matters is us and our feelings
haven't you ever heard like women saying
like leaving on Tick Tock talking about
they left to find themselves to be happy
that I outgrew him yeah those are all
stupid reasons to leave America it is it
is I left my lost relationship because
as I said on the last podcast I'm pretty
sure I felt like it was all about him
and I was like well I need to leave to
be able to do what I wanted to do and
like I still support him and what he
does but I need to move on to be able to
grow as a person and I've grown I have
grown so much well and I I gotta be
honest though that that mindset doesn't
do well in a marriage yeah not in a
relationship no I get it or even a
relationship I mean you it doesn't
matter you if people you can break up
with your boyfriend yeah if you can yeah
it's like but it's like once you got
kids involved right it's a lot it will
sound about you anymore I'm like if I
want if I have kids with you we're
staying together yeah well regardless
right but even like when you have kids
it's like you can't do what you want to
do anymore no but I think I also was
being selfish because I was like I want
to do my career and I felt like I was
being stopped I was always being told
you probably can't do it yeah you're
probably why are you doing this yeah I
mean you you probably were yeah but
that's the whole point is like you
usually have to give up something to be
in a relationship yeah but the problem
is
um now we women think that they have to
give up nothing and can still be married
you know because even your dancing stuff
I'm sure if if I was if I was um a guy
like your brother was dating a girl and
if there was like provocative dancing
like you probably he probably wouldn't
want that yeah no he definitely wouldn't
want that but then obviously you have to
explain to them this is what I have to
do in my career right but they have to
accept it in a way no they don't but
this is the thing it depends what's
important yeah so some people career is
more important than family yeah some
people family is more important than
career yeah and so you know it it just
kind of shows what you value yeah it
does yeah you know and it's not not no
not bad thing well it's a bad thing for
families yeah it's not a bit doesn't
mean you're a bad person and so a lot of
times like when I talk I think people
think I'm talking about you not you but
like yeah yeah in general people think
I'm talking about a personal thing but
it's just when it comes to families like
you do have to give up stuff you
probably aren't going to be happy for
many years yeah not and the Sparks are
gonna go yeah and yeah it's not like but
people women think more about the
wedding than they think about the
marriage like what does married life
look like yeah like yeah and like what
percent of women would get married at a
courthouse no wedding nothing just get
married nice hanky right but that's
actually I've thought about since young
age I'm like okay this is what once
where I want to get married like right
but have you have you thought about what
he would want no no but that's that's
the problem I have no but that's that's
the whole problem is like we see even
you you're thinking about the wedding
but there's no marriage yeah like what
what does married life look like like
would you serve your husband yeah yeah
that's that's good that's good most
women are going to say no to that but
but the the whole idea is like we'll
spend all this time thinking about the
wedding and not the marriage and I think
that's why we have shitty marriages
agreed and I think you need to it works
50 50. like you need to both put in the
effort well
yeah I I think that I don't like these
phrases 50 50. yeah actually I don't
believe it's 50 50. I think the men
should make the decision and the women
should support the men what kind of
decisions are you talking about every
big decision I think they can ask for
the woman's input yeah
um and she can give her opinion if he
chooses but I think it should be his
choice I think and the reason I think
this is because I think relationships
work better when women are with a man
they can trust respect and admire agreed
and I think that it works better when
the men make the final decisions because
women are emotions change every single
day yeah they've changed they changed
like everything and I think men are
supposed to protect us from ourselves
because women can be we can be very
self-destructive yes like all the women
that are on only fans if they had a
strong dad that said no you are not
doing that in a million years I think
that would be a good thing and I think
sometimes we need to be told no yes
agreed and growing up my dad was very
hard to make being like Sophia but what
are you doing don't do that yeah and
obviously having three brothers as well
I saw things that they were doing and I
was like I don't want to be like that
yeah I need to change the past that
they've gone what would they do oh just
that fashion side okay but okay
um but I saw the way that they were
going with their life and I was like I'm
going down the street but I've also been
very strong-minded since a young age
always known what I've wanted to do like
I was watching uh what's it called
Wizard of Waverly Place when I was like
five oh no way and I saw Selena Gomez
and I like that's gonna be me oh on TV
and now I'm in the background yet to be
main character you just wait I can see
it honestly um you're quite good you're
quite good I can see it who said that
you know um you definitely have like I
can tell when women have like an
entertainment Personality yeah yeah but
um but but the whole point is like I I
do think that like men should lead
because when women lead I don't think
they like the men agreed so that's why I
think at the end of the day if we want
to be happy and healthy in relationships
we have to trust the man's judgment and
support him even when he makes a
decision we disagree with and not say I
told you so later I think that's really
hard it's hard for me too I always want
to say I told you so yeah
I know I know but you know I met this
wife that was like no I never tell my
husband I told you so you know um I
always support him and and like she's
like if he wanted me off of social media
it wouldn't even be a conversation I
would just say okay no see that's part
my job I know but that's the problem is
we want jobs more than we want families
that's the problem do you want me to
make money or do you want me to be a
stay-at-home mum I think they would
prefer the stay-at-home mom see I would
like that but then I'm just going to be
bored so I need to do something I'm so
I'm so happy you're honest about this
because this is the problem is like
women get bored at home yeah correct a
lot of the time right so women aren't
even like they don't want to be like a
mother because you I mean you wanna
you're gonna get bored of your own kids
yeah but like if they're at school what
am I going to do during the day well
this is another problem and I agree with
you right I agree with you but but the
problem too is the kids are spending
more time at school than they are at
home yeah so now the school has more
influence on the kids you yes which is
why we get all like my little sister
comes out of Catholic school with a
sleep full of tattoos and blue hair from
conservative parents right yeah and and
so you know ideally I I think the ideal
situation is homeschooling the mom
homeschooling the kids yeah and I see
that because I know a little girl and
she does homeschooling she dances every
day yeah so she's career driven but
she's still learning by her mum and her
mum influences her yeah
yeah yeah so not not to say this like
but but this just shows like in society
when the women focus on themselves it
doesn't it doesn't go well yeah however
it can also like make you less social
you know I want my kids to be less
social because there's so many lunatics
out there
there's so many lunatics I wanna I wanna
vet every person my kid talks to yeah I
feel like if my mom knew how many people
I spoke to on a daily basis like just
walking around like the people that ask
me questions but why are you talking to
them yeah like there's just strangers
they've asked me a question I'm a nice
person I'm gonna talk to you and answer
your question yeah yeah no I mean I I
talk to a lot of people but I also think
that it's um it's a curse well it's been
a bit trauma you're very nice but it's
been a bit it's been a bit traumatizing
why oh I've been attacked well I mean
girl yeah yeah I mean I've been I've had
this fat chick trying to like she I mean
she didn't actually hit me but she was
going to if my friend didn't step in you
know other women threatened to come here
hit me yeah yeah because they find you
know because they find a lot of my
opinions so like um they just don't like
them but what I say is true like um I'll
say like today the the one thing that I
got today they said I hate women because
I said that 25 year olds are hotter than
30 35 year olds as a woman oh yeah
because we're younger yeah I mean that's
just clearer skin yeah clear versus skin
the less ring yes um you more and just
from an evolutionary point of view yeah
like 90 of your eggs are gone by 30. so
this idea that we can just have kids in
our 30s willy-nilly like if you if
you're single by 30 you're more likely
to not have a kid than to have one like
if you if you don't yeah I've got seven
years yeah seven and a half years yeah
yeah someone please come along so no you
know well but
would you would you stop dancing for if
you found the perfect guy and he said
hey put away the dancing shoes I want
you just at home with the kids would you
do it if I could do social media and
dance in my free time yes okay okay well
you know that's somewhat reasonable but
a lot of guys would ask would you get
rid of the social media no so but and I
want to give you an equivalent what
social media is to women it's what video
games are to men do you know how we hate
like men that are on video playing video
games all the time men do not like women
that are on social media all the time
now I say this as a woman that is you
know honest yeah clearly you know yeah
the exception doesn't make the rule
right yeah but but it is the rule so a
lot of guys guys will never tell you
this because remember they're all trying
to sleep with us yeah they are but so
they would just they would prefer us not
online yeah interesting okay yeah just
giving up your time for her in honesty
you should have considered calling Child
Protective Services that woman sounds
like a menace and her kid would have
been injured or killed if you weren't
there to make sure it didn't March off
into traffic the sad part is it probably
would have been some male delivery
driver that probably would have had to
go to prison for 10 years for
manslaughter because she wasn't watching
her kid and letting it run on the road
my dad was a cabbie for many years and
he told me there was a time when he
almost hit a kid that ran between two
parked cars and into the street luckily
he stopped in the nick of time otherwise
I might have had to visit my dad in
prison because someone wasn't watching
their child after that story whenever I
drive through traffic with cars that's
actually so crazy if a kid runs into the
road it actually I okay if you
accidentally kill somebody you get
manslaughter it actually should be on
the mom now that I've never thought
about that but if it did hits a kid that
runs into the road he can go to prison
for involuntary manslaughter or whatever
it's called but the mother gets no
consequence when she was supposed to be
watching it that doesn't make any sense
yo that's your kid you're meant to be in
control where your kid is at each time
yeah but if they just run you try well
obviously she's going to try and stop it
yeah obviously but it's his fault
because he was driving fast sometimes
it's hard because there's genuine like
accidents yeah but I'll see kids die in
the news like I saw this kid the mom was
like a tick tocker so clearly she's not
like she this woman posts all the time
on social media the kid fell off the
balcony so she's probably on her phone
instead of watching the kid so she was
more involved in social media being like
Oh I need to do this stuff that's I mean
I'm not care for the kids we don't know
right no one's there but this is my
guess so it's like I I questioned I look
at these things and I'm like should the
woman be held accountable for that or
like should she go to jail and I I'm not
gonna say yes or no but I think maybe
sometimes well it's her kid she should
be knowing what her kid is doing yeah at
each point of time if she's with her kid
yes yes down the side I slowed down in
him extra vigilant there are now also
usually blank Lanes between parked cars
and the road that gives you room to see
the crazy kids running into traffic and
it gives you time to stop on second
thought I think it's actually a bad idea
because those bike Lanes a biker might
have to stop suddenly so he doesn't hit
a kid and then he flies over his bike
over the handlebars and onto the road so
you can run over him instead how
wonderful I'm pretty sure running over a
cyclist on the road like you're Frank
from Donnie Darko would also get you
into just as much trouble what's really
pathetic about the single mother in
traffic is that she probably fought for
custody of those kids and the father
most likely fathers of those kids are
paying her money and then she's too
irresponsible to remember that she has
enough gas in her car if she ignores
that gas tank almost empty sensor light
she's probably also ignoring the check
oil engine light too maybe if you did
contact CPS in the future you'd be doing
a favor to the father or fathers so they
could potentially get their kids back
and keep them safe as for the Second
Story it ties in nicely with what I just
said guys oftentimes commit
self-deletion because they have their
lives ruined by women especially when
those women cheat on them and cuck them
with someone else's children it's
obvious if a guy finds out the kids
aren't his and keeps them himself should
the woman be go to jail for involuntary
manslaughter the same way someone would
go to jail if they accidentally killed
somebody but this was an accidental this
was intentional not the king but the so
she just lied about the kids being his
yeah but he kids no he killed himself
because he's so devastated like imagine
what your life would be like if you you
raise these kids thinking they're yours
not five you find out be traumatized
yeah yeah and so a lot of guys keep
themselves when they find out you think
the girls should go to jail I do I
actually think if a girl lies to a guy
about the kid's paternity so I think if
let's say he spent five years raising
kids that's not his I think she should
spend five years in jail however long he
wasted his time they should waste hers
to me that would be fair I almost think
double because at least you know he like
it was intentional we can't act like it
wasn't intentional yeah because she
deliberately lied to him correct and I
think like if he wasted five years part
of me wants her spend 10. I think that's
so wrong no I get you I think it's so I
understand it's a hundred percent like
in your control too the way you could
avoid jail time is not lie yeah just
don't lie in general about anything I'll
give y'all give um all the women get out
of jail free cards if I if I wasn't in
control if I ruled the world I would say
all right ladies today if you've lied
about paternity starting today you get a
clean slate confess but anybody that
lies moving forward about paternity jail
time and you get double if he's if you
lied him for six months you now spend a
year in jail he lied to him for a year
now you know the rules you get tea yes
could you get behind this this pearls
world this um this I mean it's not gonna
be me honestly because I don't know if
that's too harsh or not but I I get
where you're coming from in the aspect
of like if he's wasted his time she
should have consequences because she's
told him a lie he's wasted five years
she needs to have something I'm trying
to think of an equal equivalent alone
there's like no equal equivalent to this
time but it's interesting because men if
men Rob women of their literal money
they'll go to jail but it's interesting
because women Rob men of time and don't
but I would think that time is more
important than money and they're kind of
interesting when you think about it but
I think that innate level we have a lack
of sympathy towards men in society I
don't think it's conscious I don't think
you realize it but I think like there's
an innate like protection for women yeah
I do think women are more protected in a
lot of ways I'll give you I'll give you
an example okay if um if a woman cheats
or if a man cheats um there have been
I've seen TV things where like the women
um encourage have you and Carrie
Underwood yeah I had the name yeah so
there's a song of hers where this was a
popular song I dug my key into the side
of his pretty little cooped up
four-wheel drive carved my name into his
leather seats right yeah I put I took a
Louis V Slugger to both headlights
slashed a hole in all four tires Maybe
next time he'll think before he cheats
so we're we're saying that because she
was cheated on she can now break his sh
like this is okay no
so so but this was on like the
mainstream yeah that I get yeah why she
feels like that because she feels like
[__] because he's gone and cheated on
her with somebody else but we don't have
the male equivalent of like a man
breaking her [__] which women cheat all
the time oh yes
I think women cheat more than men but
the men don't break their [__] yeah
girls are more we will fight more I
think in those situations because we're
like we want to get revenge correct
correct so women are spiteful yes yes
not that I have not you not you no I
haven't but in general women yes I mean
I think you know everyone is but yeah
I'm like I could think of moments I like
to think I'm not but I can think of
moments where I definitely was like I do
not wish you well you know yeah yeah
yeah but I think men can like take an L
better than women and just move on where
women it's like we'll be checking on our
exes for years to make sure they're not
doing too good in general in general
yeah in general yeah yeah yeah not a
case of a single mother screwing your
friend TV I suspect it's a case of him
screwing himself over because he was in
love with her that's the thing about
love it makes us blind to the cheating
and bad behaviors our partners put us
through for the sake of sex and
procreation nature in our subconscious
mind have decided that it's better to be
a simp and sleep with women and pass on
your genes instead of being single and
happy and reaching a genetic dead end
well in our friend's case it looks like
the simping hurt him more than it
actually helped them it's the ultimate
betrayal what she did to him I really
hope that you didn't influence his
decision to end it all by saying that
she was a demon and it doesn't deserve
your love I know you were probably just
trying to sober him up after a decade or
two of having a love lobotomy when you
tell a man to start fresh someplace else
and give up on love and then he deletes
himself only a week later you really
have to think if some something you said
might have actually influenced him to
push him over the top so that he pulled
the metaphorical trigger next to his
Temple I almost feel guilty because I
probably red pilled you to some extent
and maybe you gave that guy too many red
pills and he just couldn't handle it
anymore I wonder if that would be
considered manslaughter on your part
probably not but when a guy learns the
truth about female nature and that love
is a lie you just don't know how he's
going to react to that information
that's why I suggest that you read pill
men in between relationships not during
a breakup or when they're heartbroken
they don't need more pain on their plate
at that point he and I would have waited
before getting negative and dumping more
truth bombs on his hand I don't know the
full extent of the situation but that's
what I would have done Steven you also
told him to destroy everything is it
possible that he thought you meant that
he needed to self-delete because of your
choice of words think back carefully
about what she said did he say that he
was thinking of ending at all if so did
you take it seriously enough to figure
out if it would be something like that
or not I'm not blaming you for anything
I just think it's important to think
about if anything you potentially said
pushed him over that edge or if there
was a cry for help there they might not
have been hurt as for the mother with
the three kids and no gas why did you
actually have to pour the gasoline into
her vehicle you should have left that up
to her because if anything went wrong
you would have been the one held liable
as the kid was sleeping in the car that
could potentially go up in flames you
shouldn't see walking away from a woman
in need and not helping her is a bad
thing see it as a self-defense sort of
thing you might mean well but if
anything goes wrong you know that the
woman is going to blame you even if she
wasn't watching her own kid and it ran
into traffic she'd probably blame you if
that kid got run over and got a bad case
of exploding cantaloupe head under some
Tire threats the worst thing you could
possibly do is hurt someone else when
you're trying to help them and then they
take legal action against you for being
a good Samaritan you know that when
things go wrong for women they usually
find the closest man to pin the blame
too
yeah they totally do and I'm glad that
the next time a woman needs help with
her car you're not going to be there for
I also hope that in the future when you
read pill men you'd try and do it after
they're finished instead of right in the
middle of their breakup but to be fair
he did ask you what he should do in his
life and it wasn't like you told him to
swallow a shell from a 12 gauge I think
everything he said is right I just
wouldn't have been as negative calling
his exedema I would have only done that
after he was better and trying to get
over the woman he loved anyways that's
it for today so what'd you think of this
is mgtow I don't know I think it's hard
what do you what do you what do you
think give me give me a rundown the
women is coming from and the men but
then the women should be looking after
her kid because it's her kid she should
know where her kid is at all times it's
a very interesting part of YouTube isn't
it very I'm like so like what's going on
I think they're hilarious they're
they're so done with women that they're
so blunt they just put it all out there
on the table um but let me know what you
guys think in the comments um like the
video on your way out and subscribe to
the channel and I'll talk to you next
time